there is a huge correlation between
social anxiety and social media usage I
had been diagnosed with social anxiety
and at that point in my life I could see
a friend that I was so used to talking
to at school but if I saw them in the
grocery store just passing by I would
immediately turn the other way because
my mind would immediately start thinking
what do I say what do I how do I start a
conversation how do I put my hands like
what do I do with my body language and
immediately my hands would start
sweating my heart would start racing I
would I would start sweating pretty much
everywhere I mean it was fully social
anxiety it's also important to note that
when you're anxious or when you're
stressed it increases cortisol levels in
your body which is linked to
inflammation and inflammation is linked
to pretty much every disease out there
not only does Stress and Anxiety make
you feel mentally ill but it can cause
you to be physically ill as well